coach good morning how are you yeah good
happy to still be playing that's a great
time of the year and the tournament's
been amazing and so good with all the
stuff that you know to negative stuff
throughout the year for college
basketball
what March has done with yet you know
with the start of all the conference
tournaments until now it's really been
great it's been pure and so damn
exciting we'll get to your matchup with
Syracuse in a moment we were looking at
your resume from high school the ice so
I got a good one I got a good one okay
you were in French club just by just
physically can you give me one sentence
in French coach no no I can't okay I'm
and I don't even want to go there
because language and me including
English it's at least a problem and but
I you know what I can still remember my
teacher though father Priscilla and he
was kind because I scored a lot of
points and that and to at least tolerate
me in French class you were a member of
the sock-hop committee yeah you know
because of all the athletes were you
know the and at that time that I mean I
don't know if anyone can remember it
sock hops but that was that was good but
you just wanted to meet girls so you
were on the sock hop committee to meet
girls well it's an all-boys school so
that was all the time you threw it in
the girls
okay so that was good that was a good
recruiting thing for me let's just start
of me recruiting
so you were three years on the track
team that was again that I think I just
threw that in yeah that's just filler
you weren't on the track team I don't
even I don't remember being out of track
to you so this could be one of those
things where you find out I have a bogus
background and I was my job at Duke I
don't remember being on a damn track you
lied on your resume
I did not somebody else okay all right
for me all right
I'll use that it's a political excuse
right remember in high school was
forty-four can we guess guess why you
picked 44 is there a reason why you just
number okay I don't know why I'm just
gonna go jerry west at 44 that probably
had something to do it I liked the
number and I don't know if that's and
you weren't in at that time or you know
guards should have a single digit or in
12 or something I was 12
actually at West Point I was 12 and 13
because it used to be were a long time
ago this is 50 years ago that when you
played at home he had an even number and
we had a road we had a number yeah I
remember that as well were you uh were
you recruited by a Loyola Chicago I was
not actually it's interesting that where
we're playing in Omaha Creighton was one
of the top schools for me because
Catholic school and I was a good high
school player an all-state player and I
was also interested in Wisconsin
the University of Detroit and recruiting
was a lot different at that time and
then West Point came in and and my
parents said you know forget all this
other stuff you're going you're gonna go
to West Point and it's a good thing they
did yeah that was a I'd call it the best
decision I never made we had Jim Boeheim
on yesterday and we talked to a couple
couple of things first of all on
on you and Duke sampling I didn't say
stealing Syracuse's own defense but I
did ask coach boeheim about you guys
sampling the zone defense from Syracuse
you know he's doing a great job with it
unfortunately I don't think you should
be able to use it against us I think he
should be restricted to playing just
man-to-man it's not fair but they've
done a great job they played you know a
little bit like us they have their own
way of playing things he's adjusted it
like he would always do he's a great
coach but I'm worried about their
defense but I'm really worried more
about their offense hmm did you steal
this from series no we you know did you
steal from a teacher in school and you
know I learned you know we spent 11
years together and with the US team and
we had it in case we needed it for the
US team we used it one time and but also
Mike Hopkins behind the scenes his
assistant does not did a great job at
Washington this year my assistant my
associate head coach Jeff Cable any
warned you spend a lot of time together
watching tape talking about things and
and especially Mike and Jeff talked
about not just the X's and O's of the
zone but the mentality that you have to
have and teaching it some of the drills
but also the mindset and in in doing it
and uh so yeah we we picked up a lot
from them and as we did from Thibodeau
and Nick Nolan and Dan Tony and Monty
Williams you know that was a cool part
of doing that for 11 years you you
weren't from one another and you know
for Jim yeah Jim was the day I was asked
the night I was asked to be the coach of
the u.s. Jerry Colangelo said you know
your will be allowed to pick one college
coach and then we'll have two MBA
coaches and I said
that night right away I said I want Jim
Boeheim
and and we had a chance to do that two
more times and I said I want Jim and you
know Jim's one of the smartest guys ever
to coach the game and it's a really good
friend he and his family they're just
our families are very close and you know
I'm happy that I'm not happy we're
planning us one another but I'm happy
that both of us made it to the sweet 16
Continental Tire Coach's Corner Mike
Schuh shamsky joining us Syracuse
against Duke coming up you may not be
friends with Jim Boeheim after you hear
the following where I am okay here is
the question to coach boeheim yesterday
about you if it was you against Coach K
in a shooting contest easy win for me
easy way really
he he was a defensive player it's a
Notre Dame army army yeah you know coach
tonight when he was you know he actually
wasn't good but he coached and I didn't
let him shoot too much he made him pass
to the other guard they had another
guard this isn't really I think Oxley
was July it was a really good shooter
but no I I think I could still handle
him in a shooting contest if you shot it
okay your thoughts coach no I agree with
them it's using your personnel right I
would have he would have hit more though
if I passed it to him and because I'd
know the exact spot to hit him but no
I'm okay with him being a better shooter
look at how that's uh yeah he's a better
poker player so and he's the better yeah
he's pretty damn good and the two of us
together were a really good team for us
those are days that both the two of us
will cherish and our families will
cherish
I had Reggie Miller on yesterday and he
says good you know he is really
not he is really insightful and you know
he keeps studying the game on I really
like Reggie Miller no no no I don't know
if you're gonna like what he said but he
said something nice about you he said
that you guys are the 31st NBA team I
think we have a few guys that are gonna
be NBA players and in fact I know we
have a few guys that are gonna be NBA
player but he was talking about the
offense he just said with Bagley and
Grayson that you look like an NBA
offense that's how good he thinks you
know Duke team is well I think what he
sees is that his you know they're really
outstanding college players but their
games really translate well to the
professional ranks along with Carter and
in Trent
these guys they you know they they will
be like Bagley will be a great NBA
player yeah I think Grayson will be
really good when Dell Carter I think
will be a big-time mba starter and could
be it all started and but they're you
know those Bagley in window or the other
19 and they've they've really learned a
lot this year because they're great kids
and they want to learn and hopefully you
know they can keep winning now but did
they have great futures because they're
easy to coach you know what you like I
don't know how you were as a player to
me you would I would think that times
you might be hard to coach but you know
because you would ask so many questions
do during the practice but these guys
ask good questions and they want them
they want to be really good were you
that way or yeah I don't know I nobody
that talks about you as a player I I
ignored my coach I didn't ask any
questions I ignored him so okay you were
a pain in the butt all you do is tell me
what time and you know where the gym is
and who I'm guarding or who's gonna
guard me and that's all I needed to know
coach
because I was gonna put 30 on you I mean
I I was I was gonna put 30 on you I
might give up 22 but I'm putting 30 on
you you were one of those guys who it
wasn't about what your school how much
your team score it was about what you
scored is that what you're saying yeah
pretty much so friendlier Laettner score
five players of all time in your opinion
Howard yeah yeah because you know he was
again not how it translates to the pros
or whatever but accomplishment you're
talking about for Final Fours he was in
the n-c-double-a tournament he was 21
and to come on you know I mean if you
could clone his personality would you
yeah you know for me he was one of the
great kids to coach because he would do
anything for me and the team and the
outside stuff or you know what people
because they did you had to compete
against them so he was a guy that you
know you didn't want to compete against
and you know and then he's a big
good-looking guy and he's smart and he
scores a lot of points and he wins and
okay I'm not going to like that you
start putting a twosie there and you say
okay you know at the end of the day
unless I'm a real I'm a Dukes and I'm
not gonna like this guy because he beats
everybody and yeah but he knew he was so
smart and the combination of he and
Hurley together who Hurley was the most
daring player I've ever coached that was
a an amazing combination and to had a
you know four
for three years was was incredible
well it's good to talk to you man good
luck against Syracuse yeah and well it
it'll be a really good game and you know
the tournament is so darn good in an
exciting I'm I'm I'm really happy with
how the excitement of Collins college
basketball and what it's done because
the year is kind of been a little bit
nuts
with some of the negativity about the
sport and I'll be in San Antonio we're
bringing the show there so if you want
to hold up your end of the bargain and
maybe we'll see you in San Antonio that
would be a good thing it would be one
date that I would love to keep with you
and I'm gonna bring a basketball who I
travel with the basketball hoop just to
let you know coach so if you do stop by
then we're probably gonna see what the
jumper looks like okay at ten seat not
eight seat all right free throw line
extended okay no for height of the
basket oh yeah yeah you're short guys
you know you 963 I'm strapping signals
in order to get I've seen you on a
commercial in order to touch the rim yet
on a ladder yeah but you know what the
ball always touches the net yeah it's
got to go through the rim to touch it
I'm gonna put on a shooting display and
you're gonna you're gonna say my god
Trajan Langdon just stepped on the floor
that's what's gonna put on a display for
you coach you know and I'm gonna leave
you with this okay you know I believe in
you could we sit Seton can we record
this okay coach say it again and slow it
down a little bit okay ready yeah okay
here we go yeah Dan I believe in you
Thank You coach the second one felt a
little bit more genuine this my acting
Thank You coach all right good good
that's uh it's Mike sous-chef ski
continental tire Coach's Corner whether
you're a student alumni are all-around
fan continental tire has a tire that can
get you to the big game and did you know
they're a proud supporter of 32 college
basketball teams across the United
States
show them your passion for college
basketball the hashtag is ode to
basketball for more information visit
Continental Tire dot-com back after this
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]